football was the lifeblood of former New
England Patriots player Aaron Hernandez
but did it also lead to his death
Hernandez was convicted of murder in
2015 he later died by suicide in a
Massachusetts prison best-selling author
James Patterson calls us the most
troubling crime story of our time he
takes on the true crime case in his new
book all-american murder it raises the
question of whether a degenerative brain
disease linked to football could have
caused Hernandez's violent behavior
James Patterson is here this morning
ahead of tomorrow's 48 hours special
that looks at the athletes life and
death here's a preview when I write a
book I imagine a person sitting across
me one person I'm telling him a story
and I don't want to make it up until I
finish that's where the body was found
right there by the way I did take a
pulse and the body was cold there were
45 rounds around the body no gun in the
man's wallet they found an ID Odin Lloyd
27 years old he played for a semi-pro
team the Boston bandits you got a call
from the police you found a set of car
keys enterprise rent-a-car and we
learned that my car was rented to Aaron
Hernandez both of us of football fans
pretty much everybody out there's a
patriot fan it can't possibly be that
Aaron Hernandez Odin Lloyd got to know
Aaron because they were dating sisters
and apparently they hit it off and I
knew that you know David he was hanging
out with mr. Mendez watching Aaron
Hernandez on the football field was
magical
I'm not sure you'll ever see another guy
do what he can do he signs a 40 million
dollar contract with the Patriots he's
got it made this is probably one of the
best days of my life off the field
Aaron was just charismatic if you see
Aaron he's always laughing her cracking
a joke to me a great guy the love of my
life the father of my child he had a
secret life
his father passing away was one of the
most important and damaging moments of
his life because it was when he went the
other way
Hernandez was definitely capable of
shooting his friends Aaron Hernandez was
pulled out of his home in handcuffs this
morning charged with murder this has got
to be a mistake
like involved with a murder like I could
see that I know he fooled a lot of
people into thinking he was a great guy
me I'm I'm one of them guilty to murder
in the first degree I was devastated
completely devastated and my whole world
changed he's all I know you hear stories
about the fall from grace and this might
be one of the most tragic of all time he
killed himself in a Cell just yards from
here in this Massachusetts prison he
wasn't an evil man no he wasn't he was a
sick man now what made him sick was
football 14 hours contributor James
Patterson joins us now good morning
morning we know CTE is a brain disease
that's caused and linked with should say
linked with repeated blows to the head
he his brain was given to Boston
University right what did they forget i
weirdly my niece actually who's a
neurologist at Boston she actually
handled his brain what have they found
they found that for his age he had the
amount of damp damage they'd never seen
in anybody under 45 so he had severe
damage but you think this is so much
bigger than CTE I think I think it's
much more complicated I mean you know my
eye I think if he take a guy who has
psychopathic tendencies look most people
have CTE do not kill people
I think it's it's their CTE their
psychopathic tendencies and then an
incredible amount of drug use what first
drew you to this story a lot of things
one I mean my family moved up to Boston
area when I was a teenager and until I
was a I was a Patriots fan so that's a
piece of it might my initial reaction
when I heard that he was involved was oh
my god we got Gronk and we can't be this
can't happen we can't break up this and
then because I didn't nobody believed I
mean the detectives when they found his
name on the on the key
they said it can't be that it can't be
Aaron heard as you know that Aaron
Hernandez I do think this is the most
complicated interesting murder story
unless 25 years including oj y y oj it
was a simple look whatever happened did
or didn't happen there it was one
incident here was several in sand it's
gonna kept getting worse and worse and
worse I do think that the suicide is
probably CTE related and they did and I
think he was really and during the last
year or so I think he was really off his
rocker but interestingly father figures
could appear Urban Meyer was a real
father figure for him did a great job
for him down in University of Florida
Bible study was with the mul Burnham at
the house whole time and the sheriff at
one of the prison sheriff sheriff
Hodgdon also became I think a father
figure for him and that seemed to calm
him somewhat you've given us a really
good tease this town thank you James
show this show and and what's going to
knock people socks off is this guy he's
he's so handsome his smile is incredible
he had so many gifts beautiful fiance
little baby beautiful house well really
interesting to see this James man yeah
thank you so much and you can watch
James full report all-american murder on
a special 48 hours broadcast tomorrow
night at 10:00 9:00 central it's part of
a double feature beginning at 9:00 8:00
central right here on CBS